Hi.
Please join me for a quick
tour of Google Compute Engine.
Our vision is to help
you run your applications
on the same
infrastructure we use
for hosting Google's
applications.
And Compute Engine
is three things.
It's virtual machines.
It's networking.
And it's disks.
So you start with a project.
And it's an administrative
grouping of Google's APIs.
And we have a lot
of APIs, including
other services for
compute and storage.
But right now, we're going
to focus on Compute Engine.
And here, we can
think of the project
as your virtual private cluster
to use for whatever you need.
Inside the project, we
have virtual machines,
we have networks,
and we have disks.
So the network-- and the
network is Google's network.
It's the same network we use
to serve all of our products,
and we work very hard to get
traffic from the internet
onto our dedicated
infrastructure
and get it to your
virtual machines
as quickly as possible.
And your part of this network
is private to your project.
All of your virtual machines
can see each other on the same
network, but nobody else
can see your project,
and you can't see anyone else's.
We work hard to
make it easy to use,
including a DNS server
that maps the names
of your virtual machines to
their internal IP addresses,
making it easy to configure
and connect to other machines.
The Compute Engine Load Balancer
is Google's network level
distributed load balancer,
bringing packets directly
to your virtual machines.
So you've got a pool
of virtual machines,
and Google's infrastructure
balances the load
to all of those machines.
We published a
blog post recently
with details of scaling the Load
Balancer to one million queries
per second, without any
advance warning or pre-warming.
And it only hits virtual
machines that are healthy.
And you get to define
for your application
exactly what healthy means.
So we've got networks.
We've got load balance
traffic on those networks.
And next up, we have
virtual machines.
And virtual machines
are literally
the core of Compute Engine.
When creating a
virtual machine, you
choose what balance of CPU to
RAM is right for your needs.
And these virtual
machines are all
running on Google's
infrastructure in the same data
centers we use for our products.
We work very hard to keep the
underlying machines up to date.
They get software updates.
Hardware gets replaced when it
needs to-- that sort of thing.
These virtual
machines are billed
by the minute with
a 10-minute minimum.
So you can use them in a
wide variety of situations
that just wouldn't be possible
if the billing intervals were
longer.
All of these instances boot
off of Persistent Disk,
which is a logical block
storage device that's
spread out in the data centers.
And it's been designed for high
performance and very consistent
I/O latency.
If you already have a
database you're happy with,
this is a great place to host it
and any other latency-sensitive
workloads you have.
Your virtual machines
get that high performance
and consistent I/O latency
because the infrastructure
is distributing the underlying
blocks across hundreds
or thousands of machines,
optimizing the reads
and writes to give
excellent performance.
And did I mention the
consistent I/O latency?
We strive to make it work at
the same speed all the time.
Workloads should perform
the same from day to day,
from machine to machine.
And I don't know about
you, but I really
like sleeping through the night.
So the key to that
is automation.
We've all got this virtual
machines and hardware,
so let's take advantage
of that fact--
the fact that it's virtual-- by
automating everything we can.
So we've got tools
to help, and we've
partnered with several
excellent groups
to offer services for
scaling and managing
your infrastructure.
We've also created plug-ins for
a wide variety of open source
management tools.
All of this access, all the
access to Compute Engine,
is via our HTTP and JSON API.
Everything I just mentioned.
Also our command line tools
and our developer console,
built on the same API.
This means your code
has the same access
to all the features of
Google Compute Engine.
And now you know the
fundamentals of Compute Engine.
We have a lot more details
in the documentation.
Thanks for watching.
And we're really looking forward
to seeing what you build.
Happy computing.